j'ai appris ça par la police par la
police comment ça s'est passé ici c'est
moi j'étais pas là parce que j'ai une
soeur qui était malade j'ai eu un temps
de l'année dernière j'ai été après j'ai
apprécié le lendemain et par la police
et la dîme à ma femme
voilà au bout ça a été un drame c'est
une catastrophe c'est c'est
on souffre depuis ce jour-là cesser si
c'était rattrapable
comment on peut faire pour le rattraper
moi j'essaie soeur ils sont bien
travailler il n'y en aurait bien
j'ai ça aussi parce que il y en a qui
ont cherché là il ya des problèmes y en
a qui est sur les réseaux sociaux c'est
y en a qui leur dit voilà sans péril
travail là mais moi j'ai rien fait moi
je suis le le plus on est une famille
nombreuse zone innovants on est six
enfants cinq filles lui c'est le dernier
d'accord et ils ont été bien éduquer les
gens qu'on a entendues par exemple
monsieur le président de l'association
ils nous connaissent et qu'on est ma
femme il a grandi avec elle quand notre
quartier tout le monde on aime tout le
monde et tout le monde nous aime il est
même ce petit mail à fait il affine
c'est le petit dernier la 14e place il a
14 ans il a fait la connerie
dans une fraction de seconde je sais pas
qui c'est je sais pas je le défends pas
maintenant il est il est arrêté dans une
maison fermée qui s'appelle une prison
pour les enfants et bien fait pour lui
il sera jugé
j'ai trop mal j'ai trop mal surtout pour
cette dame je suis venu pour me
premièrement pour m'excuser à cette dame
là et à sa famille et
je voudrais aussi parlé de tous les
mensonges qu'ils disent sur le ballon on
va en parler sur sur les réseaux sociaux
sur même nature sur des chaînes qui qui
passe en boucle qu'il ya des choses
c'est des gens qui viennent de pays de
payer dangereux ou de payer
et qui y vivent dans des ghettos non
c'est pas notre cas c'est pas notre cas
même des bonnes familles sa peau là pour
que leur arrivée des problèmes compte
sur sa pelouse ressortir c'est une
catastrophe qui est ambitieux sur ma
famille on en souffre tout ça quand vous
entendez les gens dire c'est la faute
des parents de l'éducation des parents
vous dites moi et moi je n'ai pas de
doute que j'ai bien éduqué mes enfants
mes trois fils ont ils ont leur bac et
l'a eu la même éducation et jusqu'à
jusqu'au jour où il a fait ça l'ait
jamais problème il n'y a pas de problème
il y avait des problèmes partir de 12
ans le maîtrise ma 14 ans elle te dire
où il veut il c'est un petit enfant dans
un grand corps ouais alors oui où il
répond qu'est ce combat qu'est ce qu'on
va lui faire moi je suis je l'avais j'ai
besoin de moi je sais ce que je veux
dire qu'est ce que je fais quoi
moi ma femme dont on parle même pas ma
femme et les malades ah oui ma femme et
déjà il est malade mais là il est à
étendre à eux c'est un drame c'est un
drame sympa
alors
quand vous avez vu les images forcément
vous avez dû être choqué ce soit hajjar
quand vous avez vu que votre frère a
fait que si vous avez envie de lui dire
vous êtes dit si c'est si ce que sa mère
était choquée et choqué vous étiez
énervé contre lui vous êtes dit si c'est
inadmissible mais je comprenais pas
surtout ouais vous le reconnaissez à la
maison avec vous il est comme on est
tous arrivent tout doucement
c'est le dernier c'est notre frère c'est
le seul garçon et c'est le dernier
il doit avec une mamie dans la chambre
dans sa chambre on a nos tentes qui
handicapée qui ne l'est pas il dort avec
elle
il lui fait mais ce massage alors on est
j'avais déjà venu pour tout le monde me
voir tout le monde voit et les gens ils
me voyais mes voisins et mais mes agents
que là il va le dire à l'autre ce qui
sape que c'était mon fils ils savent ça
et savent que et là qu'est ce qu'il ya
fait cette femme reviennent et scully
afrique puisque qu'est ce qu'il veut il
n'a pas besoin de dix ans je ne savais
pas qu'il avait 10 euros dans le sac ce
qu'ils disent les autres pour 10 euros
non c'est pas pour dix ans je sais pas
que je comprends pas ces catastrophes
c'est une catastrophe mais qu'est ce que
vous voulez
vous avez pu lui parler ou pas non non
les plus plus moi non non pas d'accord
vous agen
et plus paris quand ça ça dépend là
après du coup j'avais appris ce qu'il
avait fait tout ce que vous devez plus
paris
oui lui avait dit quoi
banon n'ait pas encore vu la vidéo la
vidéo elle est sortie le jour où il se
faisait jugé d'accord a dit quoi ils
vous il vous a dit mais il regretté vous
a dit quoi ça qui est important de
savoir
et c'est
sous-estimer il m'a dit que c'était une
grosse merde que je l'aï regretté qu'ils
savaient pas ce qui lui était arrivé ce
qui lui a pris leur et il pleurait il
n'était pas bien
ce qu'il était entraînée par des copains
comment il explique qu'il
en fait on peut pas rentrer dans trop de
détails parce que l enquête l encours
d'accord donc vous pas sur nos yeux oui
oui je peux une question monsieur
très bien vous soyez ici est très
courageux passé mais ça tout à l'heure
si règlement et ce qu'ils avaient des
soucis vous dites à partir de 12 ans
quand même il commence à avoir des
problèmes et après vous dites à 14 ans
on peut plus maîtriser il est grand et
nana monsieur à 14 ans puis maîtriser
parce qu'il a un grand corps malade mal
compris et mal compris gd jusqu'à 12 ans
et un bébé ces îles petit nice et on
peut maîtriser mais l'adolescent s'est
ainsi une période on a tous des enfants
on a tous des problèmes à l'adolescence
avec les enfants mais quatorze ans
maintenant
je lui parlais j'écris ce que je vais le
faire je lui rentre dedans je vais
parler
n'écoute pas être croit que 1000
comprend mieux que moi mais
le corps est grand mais la tête hélas
pas d'expérience est ce que vous allez
faire ça vous n'allez pas calculer les
noms les vous allez taper une femme de
derrière il vous a rien c'est fort comme
ça c'est ce que c'est normal ça non et
ben voilà c'est une catastrophe qui qui
m'est tombé dessus et ça me fait mal et
moi je voudrais vous dire si je suis
venu que tout le monde va me voir c'est
juste pour mecs que me demander des
excuses à cette dame là alors il ya sa
filiation de wierre il est dans un 11e
pardon c'est je suis venu pour ça il ya
rené qui va arriver dans un service
michel quand vous avez vu ces images est
ce que vous êtes dit
c'est vraiment il y est c'est encore un
énorme problème avec lui parce qu'il a
cumulé le problème ou est-ce que vous
n'êtes ni je reconnais pas mon fils
c'est paquin accumulé les problèmes
c'est qu'on lui parle des il a changé il
a changé à 14 ans il a changé c'est pas
c'est vrai il a des problèmes avec sa
mère où il donne moi oui les pales
jamais compenser le problème dans tous
les sens mais on n'a jamais jamais pensé
qui va n'avait jamais des problèmes de
violence avec lui sur la vidéo
sur je ne vous connais pas moi j'étais
je ne vois pas que c'est pas vous ne
connaissez pas vous dire à changer où il
a grandi fait des bd bêtise d'adolescent
mail à ses pentes d'une bêtise c'est un
délit
je ne reconnais pas ce qu'on demande
c'est safran 6 6 6 si c'est affreux
affreux ces jeunes ce qui frappe c'est
que quand on regarde le dossier ce qui
s'est passé deux des trois agresseurs
sont déjà connus de la justice oui
devant les policiers ils n'ont quasiment
manifesté aucun regret il a fallu
vraiment que les policiers les pouces
pour qu'ils disent c'est moi on n'a pas
du tout l'impression que vous parlez du
même enfant que celui qu'on voit agressé
la vieille dame c'est ça qui frappe je
trouve votre fils est celui qui sait
celui qu'offre la vieille dame non mais
voyez ce que je veux dire la violence et
là vous nous parlez d'un enfant
pratiquement sans histoire trop et un
trop grand écart
oui mais
savez quand il est dehors il va pas
venir nous dire qui skie ce qui se passe
dehors avec ses enfants avec ses
collègues et les collègues les enfants
on a honte à moi j'étais jeune aussi
n'était pas en phase i non mais ça c'est
pas pareil monsieur je dirais moi je
vous le dit les yeux dans les yeux et il
n'y a pas eu un problème d'éducation par
rapport à votre fils bien la preuve lui
a dit oui mais d'accord mais là il ya
pas qu on a tous mes médicaments j'avais
rien dire que c'est un exemple
d'indiquer sur les réseaux sociaux qui
m'a cassé il a cassé ma famille lit des
mensonges des il ne connaît pas il
invente il invente
et l jour il y avait avec monsieur
bioéthique et que je remercie un
responsable d'une association et et
aidant à la mairie il ya ma grande fille
et plus grande qu'elle qui a deux
enfants qui est marié qui accueille sans
bac qui a été bien éduqué comme la même
éducation va pas changer et les partis
ils la connaissent pas et ça pacsés
après la prit la parole ali moi je suis
la soeur de l'agresseur ils y ont donné
un micro la parler il a parlé à ce
monsieur eddy le mal qui me fait et les
mensonges quelqu'un qui dit il hélas
regretté les à dire aux gars je vais
effacer tous sur facebook et suis-moi
jeu il a changé il a changé et ce
monsieur l'âge le pardonne alors je pars
ce que je comprends je comprends le
l'acte qu'il a qui l'a fait mon fils je
suis broussailles baja garonnais qui est
là c'est le
donge elle qui a été agressée
j'imaginais bien là la peine et la haine
qu'il a eu envers votre fils 1 c'est
normal c'est non non non mais il est
venu nous voir ici c'est vrai que mal à
le comprendre il est avec pour rené là
il faudrait il voulait venir soient
honnêtes avec nous cela peut dire merci
la syrie
connaît déjà comment va comment va votre
maman déjà très mal très bon match et
reviennent m'appelait le docteur est
passé pour y mettre une minerve parce
que maintenant la le contrecoup elle
doit passer encore des examens de la
tête et
puis voilà il ya qu'à voir un cadeau
d'avoir développé la literie madame
c'est pas possible écrit comme ça c'est
secetur votre fiche ou vivre je sais pas
moi déjà je n'aurais même pas eu le
courage de monter comme vous si c'était
mon fils de la baie de la honte du geste
c'est le cooking et c'est pour tuer
c'est pas progressé depuis qu'un sac
[ __ ] 80 novembre vous n'avez même pas
besoin de la bousculer vous prenez le
sac vous le prenez le sac c'est parti
mais prennent goût comme ça
malheureusement ce n'est pas pardonnable
c'est pas pardonnable je suis désolé je
comprends très bien que ça vous privez
complément
si votre fils et puis ça va ça vous
créer des problèmes pour l'homme pour le
travail pour tous mais je suis désolé on
ne peut pas passer à côté le truc comme
ça c'est pas possible qu'à voir là c'est
la manie de la boucane amer elle est
connue ma mère mon coeur je la connais
personnellement c'est une mainmise
l'acteur ne m'est
arrivé d'être comme ça c'est pas
possible
vous seriez
je sais même pas où je suis même pas que
je trouve trop les boules je dors pas en
ce moment le seul à la voix si je dors
je vois défiler ma mère par terre au
coucher par terre je repense je la vois
morte ma mère la pauvre franchement à ma
place vous feriez quoi voilà je vais me
répondront nous croyez que votre fils y
va y arriver m j'ai pas moi qu'on va
arriver à le sortir parce que poutine
est arrivé à qu'à 15 ans faire une
agression comme ça [ __ ] mais c'est 6
je sais pas moi j'en ai fait des bêtises
je les dix autres virus mais des trucs
comme ça d'été des trucs comme ça mais
jamais hélas l'heure actuelle c'est que
c'est tous les jours qu'il y en a tous
les jours qui viennent à tous ces jeunes
c'est parce qu'ils jouent dans la
tronche depuis qu'elle irait jour là
deux machines qui se montre le cpom avec
l'autre salaire à salir et salir un gag
à la salle et à renoncer mais c'est vrai
c'est on est déjà très triste des
nouvelles que nous vous nous donnez de
votre maman vous avez pipi puis y'a pas
que pour ma maman
jean le danger on a envie qu'elle aille
mieux et là vous nous dites aujourd'hui
elle assure que ça arrête tes propos que
chaque qu'est ce que vous avez à dire à
rené bouchaïb et alger à dire à rené que
rené c'est pour moi c'est pas c'est pas
rattrapable j'ai pas rattrapé je le
cherche à retourner en arrière mais non
je ne peux pas retourner en arrière sur
les réseaux sociaux il disait la famille
se sent même pas excusé peut pas venir
s'excuser mois-ci vous m'ouvrir d'autres
portes de vienne demain avec ma famille
mon fils il a dit je vais malgré que
j'ai pas le droit c'est parce que l'
affaire est entre les mains de la
justice j'ai pas le droit de nous le
dire il regrette grave il a dit cette
femme je vais la servir je vais venir
sous ses pieds je vais je vais lui faire
les courses je vais laver ses pieds ses
affaires il a dit ça mon fils mais c'est
pas rattrapable
c'est une catastrophe ça arrive à sa
rivale n'y a pas de problème car
il est assez tomber sur votre meilleur
aujourd'hui rené
sa maman elle à 88 ans il
on espère qu'elle va aller mieux on voit
les images c'est vrai que ces jeux vous
imaginez vous mettez à la place de rené
bouchaïb les crises et qui peut faire ça
et il est si ceux qui calculent pas les
risques et s'ils seraient graves plus
grave comment on touche pas sa mort de
la salle et commence à la baisse il
avait la tête ou votre tête ou la tête
de quelqu'un de hajar qu'est ce que vous
avez à dire à rené ce soir
d'imaginer ce qui quand il voit ces
images lui quand il voit sa maman vous
imaginez vous mettez à sa place c'est
oui merci bien sûr mavs à sa place mais
je peux rien ajouter plus que ce que mon
père il a dit et c'est ce que de nom de
mon frère au nom de toute ma famille et
on va s'excuser ou à s'excuser encore
rock c'est impardonnable si vous nous
accepter on va venir vers vous et vous
allez venez à venir parce que on sait
non moi pas les gens qui m'ont fait
beaucoup de mal sur les raisons qui
m'ont brûlé je ne dors pas je dors pas
j'ai le coeur qui va s'exploser qui va
sortir de ma place elle est pardonné
parce que je veux pour muller et tu
écris c'est écrit cincinnati mais si on
a plus mais
bouchaïb aujourd'hui
vous avez peur pour votre fils aussi
parce qu'ils n'ont ils méritent ils
méritent mon fils est né dans un centre
comme je vous ai dit dans un centre
fermé et qui s'appelle prison et sera
jugé le le 30 à 22 30 novembre et
j'accepte tout ce mois maintenant c'est
la femme cette femme là que je connais
qui venez chez moi et que vous avez vous
la connaissiez wilma connaissait il va
vous parler de moi et non non mon fils
il a fait un truc qui était pas et qui
compte bien habiter affreux qui mais je
comprends pas que voyez vous je sais que
c'est très compliqué ouais mais bon je
vous dis parce que ronny il peut pas
pardonner non non non moi ta tion
pardonner je peux pas pardonner je parle
on va laisser faire les choses comme ils
doivent être faites bien c'est les
avocats qui vont qui bonnes choses ce
truc
et puis on verra on verra quand ça
passera le
c'est tout n'a pas donné de la justice
je vais pas là d'un jeu
et puis de toute manière je suis pas
tout seul je suis pas tout seul à
prendre des décisions non plus j'ai des
chaires gemini à ceux qui ont été élevés
par l'ama 1000
qu'il adore qui s'occupent plus que moi
de ma maman parce que moi je suis pas là
mais non mais non parle pas du tout au
niveau effectif je suis devant la
justice on doit l'accepter c'est plus
facile même si le pardon devant la
justice et sera condamné ou la justice
qui va donner sa parole on parle de deux
familles les voisins et la convention
l'acceptent où il a eu ce qu'il mérite
mais nous on veut que même quand on a
des six ans la mère on à dos et son
corps est ce par donges le jeu le dial
je demande pardon à toute la famille les
nièces les soeurs les frères les enfants
et si vous nous accepter on vient demain
on vient demain chez vous vous demandez
on va là parce que les gens donnent
raison je suis chez moi ils se sont même
pas excusé même s'il nous empêche n'a
pas le droit je sais pas j'ai pas vos
jeunes pour le monde pour le moment là
je veux recevoir personne j'ai déjà
plein de trucs qui m'appelle à la maison
et que je refusais
on veut rester tranquille si je suis
monté parce que honnêtement vous voulez
faire passer pour ça on n'est pas venu
le premier jour sera séparé mais auront
mais bon on vous comprend vous êtes
touchés on va pas venir à jeun alors ils
seront jugés sur pour violences
aggravées sur personnes particulièrement
vulnérables
c'est ça qui choque je sais pas s'ils
feront de la prison ou pas peut-être pas
mais la violence je vous trouve mais
encore une fois c'est courageux d'être
venu mais est ce que vous prenez
conscience de la violence quand même de
ce qu'a fait votre fils est terrible il
est terrible la dame aurait pu mourir
vous rendez compte un vieux mauvais on a
l'impression que vous cherchez quand
même à un tout petit peu amoindrir la
responsabilité de votre fils
mais à aucun moment il a dit ça la lys à
aucun moment
[Musique]
j'arrive à qui il a dit ça avec beaucoup
de coups
le site il a eu raison franchement aucun
moment et il a dit ça je sais pas où
vous avez entendu s'agit
vous entendez des choses qui sont pas
sur ce plateau 10 et moi et moi oui moi
je lui dresserait jamais la parole sauf
s'il s' s'il se tient au carreau est ce
qu'il va prendre il le mérite bien sûr
je suis pas là pour le défendre c'est
affreux mais dites-moi est-ce que je
peux me rattraper qu'il arrive pas ça ma
famille bien sûr j'ai cinq filles qu'ils
ont tous sont devant leurs copines bien
sûr nous avons l'argent peut pas au
reste de votre phrase je sais je sais du
mois je veux même simplement que ça soit
que la russie ce sera fait la grosse île
se soit fait c'est juste que ça aille au
bout des choses j'aurais dit et je prie
le bon dieu que ma mère est là mais moi
j'ai fais la prière puisque vous parce
que moi j'avais peur pour ce tout en
fait après je dormais pas amoureux né
après suis pas prêt pour lan man de
voraces y en a mais alors pas de
problème c'est une journée mais je suis
tanné c'est juste réponse à ceux qui
disent qu'on n'est même pas vous ni ses
mandants vient s'égrener rené juste dire
juste on et vous disiez la dernière fois
vous disiez comment vous en vouliez aux
parents aussi ce que vous nous disiez
aujourd'hui quand vous rencontrez
bouchaïb aujourd'hui est-ce que vous en
voyez toujours aux parents de ce qu'a
fait ce jeune homme risque au bout du
doigt la ccsi c'est-à-dire est quand
même à bord il ya quand même une
part de photogrammes parce que ce qu'il
a été bien suivi traquer les terriens je
suis pour qui les attendait les gars
comme ça si vous voulez appeler à nîmes
et président de l'association qui est de
tous les baux kassian si vous voulez on
l'appelle maintenant il voudra comme on
est mais elle a grandi avec ma femme à
femme il est né à cannes à cannes la
bocca mais alors bien avec elle mais il
vous dira plus allez-y au marché au
marché vaut mieux marcher jusqu'aux
neiges et demba moi je connais moi
comment on est jeune mais pas comme ça
je connais tout le monde l avocat moi
oui
et demandez lui demander lui-même
monsieur lisa le monde et lui je
le maire de kehl le comprends et je le
comprends ce que je le comprends il n'y
a pas quelqu'un qui
va accepter ce stade tout cas s'il est
critiqué mais
ils le méritent à dire quelque chose moi
je trouve très dur avec jg même si cette
jeune fille pleure je suis vraiment
d'accord avec rené pardon monsieur mais
il ya un moment arrêter de dire non non
non il s'est rien passé s'est rien passé
on attribue les ducs et non monsieur et
après une éducation c'est évident à 14
ans normalement on a un peu peur de son
père à son père à 14 ans on craint la
police à 14h09 ses craintes las il a
fait ça déjà s'il n'y avait pas ces
craintes la donc monsieur je suis désolé
c'est très beau les excuses mais il faut
quand même reconnaître que oui acheter
un prêt de l'éducation que oui vous êtes
responsable et arrêter de dire tout
allait bien tout allait bien peut-être
que vous avez réussi éduquer des filles
un garçon c'est pas pareil mais non
monsieur le problème par dont il vient
quand même de vous à 14 ans parce
qu'elle est responsable de son fils moi
juste sur les responsables de ce qui
fait rené s'il a fait ça aujourd'hui
c'est que vous êtes en partie
responsable je suis responsable mon fils
il aimait match mais alors je suis
responsable oui parce que je ne sais pas
si c'est le vôtre mais sur le service de
police il était déjà connu
j'étais pas le premier économique et
peser h oui c'est riche que moi je veux
pas rentrer dans sa monsieur parce qu'il
faut mieux mais on a très important ce
récidiviste est très inspirant monsieur
je
vais pas moi devancé la justice le dos
et l'autre là moi je dois même qui avait
déjà fêté mon avocate il m'a dit non il
faut pas y aller là-bas
de bêtises et plus que ça et maintenant
il faut considérer sans
régler une affaire qui va se régler
entre les mains de la justice
je suis venu j'ai montré mon visage qui
était pas pour dire qu'il ya des choses
qui se disent qu'ils sont pas vraies
alizée demandez vous avez l'âme à
l'organiser demandé à l'avocat est ce
que mes enfants et parmi eux sur comment
je vais changer l'éducation d'un enfant
à l'autre à venir nantis à celui-là je
laisse aller taper une femme qui sait
qu'il va taper une femme comme ça
excusez mon cas pas été très bien éduqué
ouah mais si vous les clés pas bien vu
que je vais pas vous dire le baliser si
vous voir vous allez juger sur
quels enfants manon
mais en fait d'emblée on a envie de dire
c'est la faute aux parents c'est la
faute d'un manque d'éducation mais on
connaît tous des familles des très
bonnes familles il ya un enfant qui sort
du lot bah voilà malgré tout c'est une
mauvaise graine sur l'instant voilà et
en même temps il ya des familles où ça
se passe très mal il ya des pépites qui
ressort parce que malgré tout chaque
individu est vraiment responsable donc
moi j'ai pas envie de vous accablez je
dis que c'est très courageux que vous
êtes là on voit comment vous êtes on
voit qu'ils vous êtes vous expliquez à
votre fille ça se passe très bien donc
on peut pas l'accabler parce que parce
que sapeur jury malheureusement c'est
arrivé à tout le monde et votre maman
est victime mais je pense que vous vous
êtes tout autant victimes parce que vous
n'avez pas choisi à la simenon ça peut
pas arriver à tout le monde
ajar que tu as à côté de toi qui est
revenu sur
hazard quai et oui quand unis pourtant
quand tu entends tu vois bien
qu'aujourd'hui toi tu étais tu été
victime de ce qui s'est passé aussi non
franchement là la salle victis et
l'atteinte à
l'environnement voyez la vidéo la seule
victime ces aides on n'est pas avec
simon est venu s'excuser mais on est sur
mon départ dont on n'est pas venu pour
que l'on a moins de trucs ou moins de
punitions c'est pas ça c'est pour dire
aux gens qu'ils sentent qu'ils disent
que la mère est là qu une seule mère et
les éduquer que par sa mère la passe de
perdre l'appel dont il a une famille et
oui là les parents ils ont proposé de
l'argent non n'a pas proposé dans la
main oui mais tu t'es foutu
même
les exclusions de voulait venir mais on
pouvait par rené mais le premier jour on
venait vous venir à l'hôpital on venir
mannion travel maintenant j'ai bien vu
il m'a dit on envoie un boulet leur dis
mais comment ils vont la prendre un
bouquet de fleurs on l'a par des
agresseurs non jeu s'annonce assez bas
alors ils les autres ils se sont même
pas excusé mais j'aurais juste aimé
monsieur je vous disais juste oui c'est
de ma faute aussi ces jeunes là dit il
l'a dit
la ligne le redire vous avez dit à yves
officielle à 14 ans c'est moi le
responsable il l'a dit il l'a dit et
j'ai dit c'est une catastrophe qui est
tombé sur moi et merci beaucoup et
maquilleuses et des choses qui arrivent
en battant son service juste un truc la
porte à tous des problèmes est ce qu'il
ya quelqu'un ici qui a permis assuré non
mais bien tout va bien il n'y a pas deux
que c'est notre c'est une famille de six
enfants il ya plein d'ados difficile
alors l ac c'est extrêmement grave ce
qu'il a fait c'est inadmissible moi je
pense avant tout à angèle et à rené
parce que quand je vois rené comme ça ça
me fait ça me fend le coeur et comme à
tous les téléspectateurs parce que rené
voilà à chaque fois et qui vient serrer
qui on est on est vraiment au sous
l'ironie nous fait une peine immense et
on a tellement envie que quand je l'aï
eu mais aujourd'hui bouchaïb l'a dit
c'est de sa faute aujourd'hui le
problème qu'il a lui aussi il est
aujourd'hui l'un puisse enfin ça s'est
passé à partir de gaza par mer donc est
ce qu'il va faire je veux bien qu'il
soit suivi par un psy je veux bien que
je me suis dit cela il m'aide
il faut qu'il soit bien suivi parce que
c'est un problème ça on le comprend
est-ce que c'est compréhensible ça à
part dire pardon aurait manqué ce qu'est
ce qui peut dire madame hanche je suis
en décalage total ce que je le monsieur
que je vois j'ai pas l'impression que
c'est son fils qu'à taper je vous dirai
ce qui est posé et bien sûr que ça vient
et hajar aussi je demande pardon je ne
pense pas qu'il soit venu là pour
éteindre des polémiques sera sur les
réseaux je vois des gens sérieux
l'éducation elle peut échapper à tout le
monde on n'est pas sur quatre cantons à
un gosse de 14 ans on n'est pas 24
derrière lui on n'est pas 24 avec ses
fréquentations on sait pas où il va
maintenant je les dis moi si on fait ça
ma mère je suis je serai 100 sans pitié
pour votre enfant vous comprendrez moi
c'est moi quand j'ai aussi je vous vois
vous j'ai pas l'impression que vous êtes
un mauvais père j'ai pas l'impression
que nécessairement foutisme vous aidera
à équilibrer vous parlez vous faites des
phrases c'est censé vous êtes quelqu'un
d'équilibré de sensé et je trouve que
cette histoire allait vraiment vraiment
triste et j'espère rené va peut-être
accepté un espèce de petit pardon
maintenant il faut que la justice passe
failli parce que votre fils je vous le
dise droit dans les yeux il a fait la
vermine et c'est une vermine votre vie
sur il faut leur équilibre et leur met
dedans et je vais danser un message à
tous les autres jeunes les autres gens
qui nous regardent regarder dans quelle
situation vous pouvez emmener vos pairs
aimez vos familles regarder ce monsieur
qui est venu ce soir devant des millions
de téléspectateurs
quant à cowes pour dix mâles pour 12 mal
à regarder dans quelle situation un père
honorable qui travaille à l v6 enfants
vous l'avez mis comme on dit la hchouma
devant des millions de téléspectateurs
[Applaudissements]
rené sa peine est immense et bouchaïb il
la comprend hadjar aussi et il est
impuissant maintenant je vous dis il ya
des familles ou l'éducation et est très
suivie et où un moment où il ya un an 20
des enfants qu'ivry et c'est que
maintenant on peut rien faire je suis
désolé un moment tu vois tu peux pas et
tu peux pas être derrière lui à chaque
fois et c'est vrai que voilà aujourd'hui
quand je suis un peu comme toi moi quand
je vois bouchaïb et à hajar je me dis je
j'hallucine en fait tu mené par m
comment comment qu'est ce que je me dis
unis qu'est ce qui s'est passé pas une
famille dans la fenêtre de son fils
exactement et c'est vrai que pourquoi ça
a été ça non mais et ça prouve aussi ça
prouve aussi que les fréquentations la
fréquentation
des copains les fréquentations les
réseaux sociaux etc aujourd'hui beaucoup
plus dangereux et que on peut avoir la
des parents qui sont qui donne une
éducation tout à fait correct et normal
et derrière il ya un des enfants ben et
qui brille est aujourd'hui bouchaïb je
le dis
son fils il faut l'accabler les premiers
à l'accabler mais aujourd'hui à part
demander pardon qu'est ce qui peut faire
de plus aujourd'hui il est ici non mais
c'est vrai que c'est compliqué et je
pense qu'il doit être aussi dans
j'imagine comme vous vous sentez mal de
voronin parce que moi je me sens déjà
très mal de vendée parce qu'on a
tellement peur pour angers qui voilà
qu'elle est d'aider des séquelles et
quelle voix laquelle ce second adélaïde
à nous donner des nouvelles assez
préoccupante c'est vrai que aujourd'hui
je me dis devant rené vous devez vous
dire mais qu'est ce que je peux faire
qu'est ce que je suis qu'est ce que
j'aimerais faire beaucoup mais
aujourd'hui rené ça lui rendra pas la
santé de sa maman parce que c'est un mot
il était ce qu'est ce qu'elle a vécu
quand il revoit les images c'est vrai
qu'il nous avait dit la dernière fois ci
l'avait croisé votre fils il aurait pu
avoir un comportement et il a dit voilà
il a dit je l'aurais tué c'est ce qu'il
a dit là niveau je l'aurais je suis
jeune et et l'âge et c'est vrai que
rené on est je suis très mal j'ai le
coeur qui va exploser j'ai pas dormi
depuis j'ai trop trop mal trop trop mal
et qu'on m'appelait j'ai eu hier j'étais
à casablanca j'ai pris l'avion je suis
venu et j'ai trop mal pour votre maman
il est trop mal de ce qu'il a fait mon
fils et toute la famille ils ont trop
mal mais malheureusement on peut pas
retourner en arrière mais je peux pas
assez je peux pas le rattraper c'est
votre maman je la connais je la voyais
tous les samedis c'est une femme très
très gentil c'est tombé sur ces scènes
destin je sais pas je suis ma merde
c'est pas ma mère elle y était sur le
marché de la banque allemande et les
fromages mais j'ai acheté chez eux et le
fromage suisse et votre tante les
légumes frais du jardin j'achète que
chez elle il vient il achète chez moi au
nez mais c'est un destin c'est arrivé
c'est arrivé qu'est-ce que vous voulez
qu'on fasse qu'est-ce que vous voulez
qu'on fasse moi je veux que ça m'arrive
je veux aucunement que ça m'arrive ça
j'ai que ça à faire j'ai l'habitude tout
va bien il ya que ça qui me manque mais
c'est arrivé qu'est-ce que vous voulez
que je dise rhône et je vous demande
encore de me pardonner et de demander à
toute la famille s'il vous plaît qu'il
pardonne ma famille je suis responsable
de ce qui la fait mon fils mais jamais
je suis d'accord avec déjà mais je
voudrais qu'elle fasse à jamais les et
là étaient nos rides on travaille les
sites mange jamais on travaille où on
les nourrit on l'est on leur achète pour
qu'ils étudient pour qu'ils travaillent
j'ai appelé mon autre médecin traitant
il vous dira qu est ce qu il a dit je
les appelais je n'ai pas trouvé pour
kiel pour kiel pour qu'il parle ici pour
qu'ils se parlent notre médecin traitant
qui nous a suivis de qu'il a suivi l de
bébé qu'est ce qu'ils fabriquent et avec
tout le monde je suis venu c'est
passionnant que d'erreurs mais on est
nous on est gentil tout ça tout le monde
nous aime bien pourtant là on habitait
puis surtout ma mère année à cannes donc
mes mouvements et son clavier comme je
dis parfois là c'est pas un problème
d'éducation c'est un problème de
fréquentation - et ce à un moment voilà
les
ccc aussi sot c'est un drame pour vous
ce qui arrive et il faut que les gens le
sachent aussi que pour vous c'est
dramatique ça assez
voilà c'est beaucoup plus voilà je vous
dis comme vous avez eu raison de le dire
à jaar tout à l'heure la seule victime
c'est angèle la sereine et aujourd'hui
vous aussi vous êtes dans une situation
où fait compliqué parce que l d'un match
à part dire pardon et à part essayer de
faire le maximum pour que angèle aille
mieux que et vous excuser devant on a
emmené son fils c'est compliqué pour
vous parce que vous êtes vous êtes vous
êtes responsable parce que c'est votre
fils mais vous pouvez vous avez vous ne
cautionnez pas du tout ce qu'il a fait
c'est bien normal et aujourd'hui vous
venez dire aussi que il ya eu beaucoup
beaucoup de choses qui sont dites qu'ils
sont fausses voilà sur les réseaux 1
vous n'avez pas proposé d'argent s'il
faut vraiment bien leur dira jamais non
non non non il n'y a pas eu de voix là
si j'ai fait d'autres sorties jeux truc
verizon sur les je voudrais dire si il
n'y a pas d'antécédent judiciaire pour
le palu est fils de bouchaïb en sont les
deux autres comme je dis voilà c'est
aussi les réparations qui font que
aujourd'hui on arrive à des drames comme
ça et c'est pas vraiment vous êtes
l'exemple
aujourd'hui l'exemple vous montrez
l'exemple que ce n'est pas que la faute
parfois départ on voit là et que
l'éducation c'est c'est ainsi les
parents des deux autres en sait pas
quand il sent sa maman c'est les
connaissais pas on sait pas comment ça
on va pas les casser les codes et cialis
de vous les connaissiez les données de
l'onu john holmes et qu'il moi je
connais même mois tous les garçons les
5000 me salis je connais même pas leur
nom d'accord mais vous savez je rentre à
la maison et je sors travail je les
connais tous et le prennent avec moi
même les courses je le pense tous je les
connais tous et aussi nos amis on les
aime mais les noms je connais pas je ne
sais pas rené j'aimerais que tu essaies
de le mot de la fin parce que des
machines et je suis désolé je continue à
dire ce que je suis désolé mais pour le
moment je pour moi déjà je pas le truc
de pardonner quoi que ce soit et en plus
je suis pas tout seul je pense que deux
du côté de ma famille c'est pareil pour
le moment
on verra peut-être plus tard mais il
faut laisser le temps que le plus
important c'est quand je vois mieux
laisser le temps que ma maman déjà là
les à-coups mieux et puis que la rage
par un peu parce que
bien sûr elle est là chez les bouley il
aurait dit on il aurait été dans une rue
mal a même rajouté un sujet j'éduque
j'ai du mal à le digérer je vous dis
bien sûr moi je sais pas ma maman
j'avais je travaille tous les jours ma
maman c'est à lui son corps et un
changement je ne fais que des conneries
dans mon travail parce que dans la seine
je c'est normal en tout cas on espère
qu'on gèle valait mieux h je voudrais
remercier rené delcroix plaindre faire
le truc j'ai pas l'habitude de faire des
trucs comme ça j'aime bien ça
malheureusement je suis désolé pour vous
c'est sûr que ça vaut créer des
problèmes que vous n'êtes pas fautif à
100% mais
malheureusement pour le moment moi je
peux pas pardonner sur nation merci rené
en tout cas d'être venu nous voir
merci d'avoir été là merci beaucoup à
vous deux